44 acuerdos plasmados en un documento
este fue uno de los resultados de la
sexta cumbre de la comunidad de estados
latinoamericanos y caribeños celac a
pesar de las diferencias ideológicas
entre las naciones un aspecto que unió a
todos los países asistentes fue el
manejo de la pandemia si algo nos ha
llevado a reunirnos de hacer lado
diferencias que ha sido este año y medio
la pandemia
américa latina y el caribe tiene más
muertes que ninguna otra región del
mundo también se llegaron a acuerdos
relacionados al medio ambiente sobre el
que se pactó un fondo compartido para
hacerle frente al cambio climático en
cuanto a los temas económicos los países
optaron por adoptar una postura común
frente al fondo monetario internacional
que vamos con el fondo monetario
internacional aquí está se llegó ese
acuerdo
para decirle oye es muy desigual en el
acceso a los recursos y las reglas del
juego para nosotros es deuda para
ustedes pues son simplemente otras
facilidades para los países
desarrollados
en el encuentro países con méxico y
panamá expresaron su preocupación frente
al aumento de migrantes que intentan
atravesar sus territorios para llegar a
eeuu para mi pequeño país para panamá
hace algunos meses llegaban llegaban
apenas 800 migrantes
hoy en día llegan más de 20 mil al mes
durante la cumbre también se desataron
tensiones derivadas de la petición
mexicana de eliminar el bloqueo a cuba y
la presencia del presidente nicolás
maduro por el que estados unidos ofrece
una recompensa